even though it's Pennywise brags about
being everything you're afraid of there
are plenty of clowns who may be even
scarier than the extra-dimensional
terror monster and we're not talking
about those kind of creepy clowns from
pee-wee's big adventure or even the
insane clown posse there are some very
real reasons to develop a serious case
of bozo phobia here are just a few sweet
tooth needles Kane better known to
gamers as sweet tooth is a serial killer
clown who drives a well-armed ice cream
truck in an apocalyptic demolition derby
he's been driving that terrible truck
since the first twisted metal game in
1995 Andy's only gotten creepier since
over the course of the original twisted
metal series he evolved from a standard
killer clown with green hair to a
flaming cursed monster who's forced to
carry the fires of hell around with him
sure the fires of hell are pretty scary
but the 2012 twisted metal reboot made
the clown even creepier making him a guy
who tries to kill his entire family
after going insane with boredom
sweet-tooth spends years trying to find
his daughter who escaped the killing
spree so he can finish what he started
it's just video game fun that causes
other people to get killed along the way
the Joker he's a force of pure chaos and
Batman's greatest enemy the Joker is at
various origin stories over the years
and they tend to involve falling into a
vat of chemicals while trying to escape
Batman but who he was before that is up
in the air in his original 1951 origin
he was already a villain known as the
Red Hood 1988's The Killing Joke graphic
novel elaborated on this story making
him an aspiring comedian who had only
turned to crime to support his pregnant
wife but even within that book this
sympathetic backstory is called into
question with the Joker saying that he
prefers his past to be multiple choice
for every new Joker there's a new origin
story that lack of clear identity is
what the Joker is all about he's
dedicated to the idea that the world
makes no sense
and will murder maim and mutilate anyone
who crosses his path to illustrate that
there are no reasons
he's not just a mad clown he's a clown
that embodies madness
[Music]
twisty few clowns have ever been as
visually frightening as twisty the
deranged killer featured in freakshow
the fourth season of American Horror
Story creator Ryan Murphy has even said
that members of the crew would leave
during twisty scenes because he was just
so frightening
once a circus clown who loved entertain
children twisties career was ruined by
false rumors of pedophilia he failed at
committing suicide with a shotgun but
succeeded in blowing off his lower jaw
thus the half mask with the terrifying
smile what's underneath is even more
horrific leaving reality entirely behind
twisty begins kidnapping children in a
supposed effort to save them from their
oppressive parents these convinced
children still love him and long to be
entertained by his antics even as every
child who sees him screams and runs away
may be that horrifying mask was a bad
choice madcap the best thing about a
killer clown is that you can usually
kill it but that's not the case with
madcap Marvel's cloudiest supervillain
he first appeared in Captain America
number 307 as a nemesis to the
all-american hero and his pal Nomad but
he doesn't seem to care much about
superheroes at all until they get in the
way of his goal of spreading chaos
madcap has two superpowers first he
can't be hurt or killed a knee injury
suffers heals almost instantly and if he
dies she comes back to life second he
can make other people behave
irrationally by making eye contact with
them making ordinary citizens put
themselves in danger by dancing through
traffic or even leaping off of buildings
a clown who will kill you is scary but a
clown who cuts off his own fingers just
for fun is even scarier the poltergeist
clown 1982's poltergeist is one of the
all-time greatest haunted house movies
and like most standard haunted houses a
lot of the horror early in the film
comes from inanimate objects moving on
their own so when young Robbie notices
late at night that a clown dial that was
sitting in a chair by his bed has
suddenly disappeared that's already
scary and then things get really bad
the 2015 poltergeist remake over does
its attempt to one-up this scene with
multiple clown dolls in a much darker
room but nothing in that film measures
up to the scares of the original
violator few clowns are actually from
Hell but the violator is a straight-up
demon he's the main antagonist and Todd
McFarlane's spawn comics as well as the
1997 spawn movie every time on somebody
far code a demon catches a wings on his
entire purpose is to mess with spawn who
has given his powers by the forces of
hell since those powers will eventually
run out and force spawns return to hell
for all eternity the role of violator is
not just a tempt and corrupt spawn into
doing evil it's to manipulate him to use
its own powers recklessly violator isn't
just a murderous clown he's here to
Shepherd a soul toward eternal damnation
and he does it with a grin clown
perhaps no clown ever created is as
terrifying as the creature at the center
of clown an ancient demon that devours
children clown takes over anyone who
puts on the cursed clown costume which
is made from clown's own skin and hair
in the film this happens to Kent a
regular dad who's just trying to provide
last-minute entertainment at his son's
birthday party once he puts on the suit
he begins transforming into an inhuman
kid chomping monster at first the horror
of clown comes from Kent's loss of
control as the demon takes over but by
the end of the film there's no saving
him and the horror comes from the
rampaging monster clown that he's become
you can be sure of one thing this is the
scariest clown in movie history and
there's never been a better
advertisement for chucky cheese
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all the school stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]